[Music]
Not only Sarada, but even Sasukekuni said something nasty
.
I'm really worried about Sarada, but I'm worried about you, my
sister, aren't you worried?
That's all I think I'm prepared for when an emergency happens I'm all like
that, but even if I
know the victims,
there are times when I can't help my feelings
It's too late now that I remember things from the past
so well I'll try to somehow become stronger
That's what all of us did back then,
yeah, we
were desperate
[music]
And you told me a long time ago that girls have to be tough to survive,
yeah yeah yeah yeah
It's scary to think that something might happen to a kid with a stomachache But
I thought I should trust him I believe
they're tough too
[Music]
You to me  I forgot that I showed 20 stitches to win
.  But
what about Sakura-chan
[music]
I